hi my name is mia healey and i play
shelby goodkind hi my name is jenna
claus and i play martha blackburn hey my
name is erina james and i have to play
tony chalifoux
hi my name is raine edwards and i play
rachel reed hi
i'm shannon berry and i play dot hi i'm
sophia ali and i play phat
hi i'm sarah pigeon and i play leah rope
and we're the cast of the wild and we're
here with buzzfeed to play a game of
who's who
who's most likely to survive on a
deserted island
it's got to be shannon yeah yeah yeah
she's like dot
i think out of us four i reckon i can
urane
see i start from 50 50. if there's like
no bugs on the island then for sure rain
but if there's bugs then it's not
happening
she's a rock oh thanks ben i was
choosing between shannon or sophia i
feel like if it was between her and
sophia she would sacrifice herself
and like sophia is sort of this underdog
that no one's expecting to win but she
would just come out of the woodwork and
like
take it off rather than just me
yeah i didn't know that yeah you could
just like make a plan and you would have
like a clear course of action before you
did anything which i think would be
really
integral to you making good decisions
who's most likely to make other cast
members
laugh in the middle of a serious scene
you made me laugh and you didn't do
anything
i have that line where like supposed to
like freak shelby out and she was
playing it so real where she was just
like
i looked at her and imagined her doing
it again and i lost it
who's most likely to win survivor sarah
cannon
i think shannon because one dot loves
survivor so i think
some of that knowledge and wisdom that
she's gained through playing his
character of dot would inevitably help
her win survivor
it also has to do a lot with
interpersonal relationships and like
making allies
i think that shannon would excel at that
she's saying that i'm very manipulative
it has to be shannon i feel like out of
us for maybe
i don't know i give it a good go i think
i like the mind games of it like i was
watching it recently and you've got to
pick
you know your tactic and you're quite
confident in a good way
who's most likely to pull a prank on set
i was too tired all the time i don't
know
yeah no i don't think we had any like
real pranks we just had like people that
were just funny
sarah yeah oh no because remember when
you told everyone
jeff was going to come to set and
everyone believed you
jeff bezos is showing up yeah jeff bezos
is coming like he's coming to set today
like wait who believed her who's the
first person to want to go camping and
who's the last person to want to go
camping
did you say you yeah who's the last
person to go camping
rain helena oh no rain i changed my
answer now green hate
bugs oh rainbows hate bugs
she'd come in handy can't camping like
because she has all
of the two oh she has so much stuff yeah
that backpack she just
yeah she has that backpack and she has
everything you need in it i was meant to
go camping last weekend i love it you do
say that a lot of stuff
i don't know if i could actually do it
but i'd like to talk about it i feel
like i'd be the last person to want to
go camping i mean my boyfriend lives
like in the country and stuff so i mean
i kind of do all this time
in a way but like i don't want to who's
best to give you relationship advice
you are yeah i was going to say mia you
and i erin were giving a lot of just
relationship advice to each other you
gave me so much advice
while on set yeah i did and i love
giving you advice
we used to just sit out on sofia's hotel
balcony and just like talk the whole
night away be like please help me
i don't know what to do you're so wise
i said sarah because same i just feel
like she's really wise
oh who's least like their on-screen
character
yeah or jenna really jenna yeah i think
jenna
i feel like jenna has this grounded
self-confidence that you know martha is
trying to find throughout the show
i said mia oh yeah mia mia yeah me too
she's the opposite
you make a good point me uh surely yeah
i would have to say
myself i feel like we're all like
different and similar to our characters
though in like
ways yeah who is most likely to be found
at craft services
i feel like it's me guys it's gotta be
you i feel like you can definitely have
around for that one listen because craft
services in new zealand is way different
from craft services in the u.s
you guys have like a little platter and
i'm used to like a buffet
right oh
she was always eating an orange i don't
know why and then like
offering slices like her hands like
covered in juice like you want an orange
slice
it was funny too is that no one would be
like no people would just be like yeah
who is most likely to tag someone in a
meme
erena or shannon to be fair she comes
out with some rogue ones
or just makes her own memes as well like
turns herself into a man and just like
sends them out to everybody
we send millions of tick tocks back and
forth now
i love memes but i also don't like them
at the same time
they're just so stupid and i'm like why
did i waste my time reading that would
you like to be a meme though
100 even if it was a negative one who's
best at doing impressions
of other cast members my favorite
impression to do was of erima
when it came to the dance
man it's not
oh no one needs to say it that can
actually stay and die on bethel's beach
i
personally love when the americans try
to do like aussie and indeed accents and
they go like
oh yeah sounds so wrong
i think i was like art department yeah
i don't know actually is really good
and very into character as us i've seen
her do
me before which is really funny i've
seen mia do like edna or
shannon her impression of me or yeah all
year i wonder if i could do shannon yeah
go on but something that you would say
oh i know something should say i'm
heading down to the river you do some
fishing
in the dinghy get to the server pick up
some cities
and knock your lights out and knock your
legs out
people are gonna think that all the time
now i say gotta go down in the dinghy
and do some
fishing thanks buzzfeed thank you
everyone for watching and make sure to
watch
the wild on amazon prime december 11th
you